if you had to choose right now how long
would you want to live 80 years 90 120
longer and do you think you'll change
your mind once you reach that age fifty
thousand years ago most humans died very
young as we learned how to use the
resources around us to treat ourselves
there's got better and better today
humans are living longer and healthier
lives than ever before but this has an
unforeseen consequence we spend an
ever-increasing part of our lives being
sick and in need of care most of us will
die in a hospital bed which is
depressing enough by itself but we also
have to witness the same happening to
our loved ones except maybe we can stop
this forever the most effective way to
treat a disease is to prevent it
it saves many more lives if you stop a
million people from smoking than coming
up with better chemo therapies so why
not put a halt to the cause of all
disease the process of Aging in a
nutshell aging is caused by physics and
not biology think of cars arts we're
down from rubbing and grinding metal
rusts filters get blood rubber cracks
our bodies are worn down by trillions of
tiny physical processes oxygen radiation
from the Sun our metabolism our bodies
have many mechanisms to repair this
damage but over time they become less
effective cell our bones and muscles
weaken our skin wrinkles our immune
system gets weaker we lose our memory
and our senses diminish there's no such
thing as dying of old age we all die
because one of our important parts
breaks the older we get the more damaged
and fragile we become until one or
multiple diseases take over and kill us
unnoticed by most of us longevity
research has made some unprecedented
advances in the last few years for the
first time we're starting to understand
the mechanisms behind aging and how to
manipulate them aging is neither
mystical nor inevitable and we might be
able to stop or delay it during your
lifetime
we'll discuss the science behind it and
how scientists are trying to stop it in
another video but first if we could
should we end aging is this a good idea
the end of aging or life extension makes
many people uncomfortable we're born a
young become older and then we die this
has been the natural order for literally
all of human history and getting old is
a good thing right we celebrate the idea
of living long enough to experience old
age we even call them the golden years
but the reality is that everybody wants
to become old but nobody wants to be old
think of the Greek myth of toothiness
for example Tiff's furnace was the lover
of the goddess adios and probably an
amazing dude because she begged Zeus to
grant him immortality so they could
spend eternity together but she forgot
to specifically ask for eternal youth
till earnest was granted eternal life
but he kept aging unable to die after a
few hundred years he was reduced to the
size of a grape babbling on senselessly
forever
thousands of years ago humans already
fears never-ending old age but ending
aging does not mean getting weaker and
weaker if you become too old it's too
late a 90 year old who stopped aging
would die anyway after a few years too
much damage has been done to his
internal machinery there are already too
many surfaces for disease to attack
instead the concept of life extension
promises to ends diseases and with them
the end of a fixed maximum age we don't
know how much we could prolong our lives
we might make every human healthy to the
currently accepted maximum age of around
120 or we might stop biological aging
and disease indefinitely nobody knows at
this point what's possible okay but even
if we could achieve that should we well
life extension is ready just another
phrase for medicine all the doctors are
doing is trying to prolong life and
minimize suffering the vast majority of
healthcare resources are spent on the
consequences of Aging nearly half of
your lifetime healthcare costs will be
spent during your senior years and
another third during middle age we are
actually already trying to prolong life
with our current medicine we're just
doing it very inefficiently trying to
stop aging from happening is not less
natural than transplanting a heart
treating cancer with chemotherapy using
antibiotics or vaccines nothing humans
do nowadays is purely natural anymore
and we enjoy the highest standard of
living ever as a consequence of that
what we're doing right now is waiting
until it's too late and the machine is
failing and then we use the vast
majority of our resources trying to fix
it as well as we can what it brings down
even further but life-extension still
feels hubris t'k most people assume that
they will want to die once they reach a
certain age and this might still be true
the idea of avoiding death entirely is
off-putting for many the end of
biological aging would not mean the end
of death in any way
it's more like a summer evening when you
were a kid and your mum called you
inside you just wanted to keep playing
have a little more fun during sunset
before you went to sleep it's not about
playing outside forever just a little
longer until we feel tired if you
imagine a world without disease where
you and your loved ones could live in
good health for another 100 or 200 years
how would this change us would we take
better care of our planet if we knew we
would be around longer if we could work
for 150 years how much time would we
spend figuring out what we're good at
how much more time would we spend
learning would the intense feeling of
pressure and stress many of us are
feeling right now go away
or get worse so ask me again if you
could choose how long to live right now
in good health and with your friends and
family what's your personal answer what
would you like your future to look like
but maybe you are still unconvinced some
nagging feeling remains that is the
Reaper whispering into your brain watch
my video to hear what he says and why
you shouldn't listen your eternal future
may depend on it
go watch the other part over at C GB
Grace Channel and if you're not already
subscribed subscribe